[Música]
y en France 24 es momento de hacer un
repaso por lo que titula la prensa
internacional y por eso vamos con esta
revista de prensa a cargo de Marta Moya
Marta Buenos días Hola Valentina feliz
viernes feliz viernes también Vamos
nosotros a abrir este espacio con los
reportes de los medios internacionales
sobre el fatal desenlace del sumergible
implosionó en su exploración de las
ruinas del Titanic es una noticia que ha
estado en el foco mediático del mundo
durante la última semana Así es
Valentina tanto en portadas de la prensa
escrita como en portadas de web de todos
los medios internacionales ha estado
esta semana esta noticia que ayer
llegaba como decíamos al fatal desenlace
tras muchas jornadas de angustia la
guardia costera de Estados Unidos
anunció ayer que la nave sumergible de
6,5 metros de largo
2,8 de ancho y dos y medio de alto
habría implosionado por la presión de
las profundidades oceánicas sobre la
cabina dice el país un juguete caro de a
250 mil dólares el pasaje que acabó
convirtiéndose en un ataúd flotante se
hallaron cinco piezas del revestimiento
exterior de este sumergible y según las
hipótesis iniciales habría podido
implosionar cuando se perdió la conexión
con la nave exterior además ha hablado
el copropietario de Ocean Gate la
empresa de este sumergible que se llama
Guillermo solheim y ha dicho a la bbc
que podría verse tratado de una
implosión instantánea mientras fuera
hacíamos el recuento de cuánto oxígeno
les podría quedar a estos tripulantes
del sumergible pues es muy probable que
a 4 kilómetros de profundidad casi no
hubiera ningún tipo de Esperanza para
estos cinco tripulantes el despliegue de
medios técnicos ha sido absolutamente
brutal en estos cinco días movilización
de recursos técnicos de muchos países
por tierra y por agua de hecho fue un
robot teledirigido por un barco
canadiense quien halló estos restos y el
despliegue no solo fue técnico sino que
también fue mediático y esto nos ha
hecho repensar un poco donde ponemos el
foco informativo Porque mientras
hablábamos del sumergible por ejemplo 39
migrantes morían ahogados en las costas
de las Islas Canarias en España
Valentina y precisamente es que esta
diferencia en la cobertura de las dos
tragedias nos reportan de manera muy
gráfica los viñetistas de Cartoon
movement si Valentina muy gráficamente
hemos destacado cuatro viñetas que
alarman un poco de pues donde ponemos No
la mirada periodística en el cubrimiento
de estas dos tragedias por empezar hemos
destacado una caricatura del jordano
emahayak en la que se ve una cámara de
televisión sumergible literalmente dando
la espalda a mil Bueno a cientos de
embarcaciones de migrantes y centrando
únicamente su atención en el titán la
segunda viñeta que hemos destacado es
del austriaco el de la austriaca Perdón
Marian quemensky que se ve a dos manos
saliendo del océano una con billetes de
dinero y es la que atrae el bueno el
bote salvavidas la tercera es del
italiano Paolo lombardi que vemos una
embarcación de migrantes con uno de
ellos poniendo con pintura el nombre de
titán en esa embarcación para ver si eso
pues es una llamada de que van a recibir
Socorro y la cuarta es del neerlandés
mokassen que se ve a un barco que
naufragó en Grecia la pasada semana y al
titán ambos pidiendo ayuda y al final
Pues esa mano de Socorro solo llega al
sumergible que nos hace repensar un poco
también pues como tenemos que cubrir las
tragedias migratorias claramente una
reflexión bastante directa bastante
fuerte vamos a cambiar radicalmente de
tema porque ayer inició el juicio contra
el expresidente brasileño Jair bolsonaro
lo estábamos hablando y la prensa
brasileña Pues nos está dando algunas
pistas sobre este proceso si Valentina
hemos destacado dos artículos primero
con la Joya de Sao Paulo abrimos porque
ayer bolsonaro dijo que Estados Unidos
podría estar detrás de las elecciones de
2022 que finalmente le dieron la
victoria electoral a Lula da Silva ayer
empezó como decimos el juicio en su
contra qué podría llegar a inhabilitarlo
durante ocho años el expresidente no
quiso perder la ocasión de hablar sobre
otro reportaje que había sido publicado
dos días antes por el medio financial
Times y que hablaba de cómo Estados
Unidos se movilizó para impedir
cualquier tipo de insurrección por parte
de los bolsonaristas Estados Unidos dijo
que reconocería al ganador de las
elecciones de manera muy temprana para
evitar cualquier acto de violencia
porque como sabemos bolsonaro estuvo
durante meses cuestionando y negando el
sistema de votación electrónica que es
precisamente por lo que está siendo
juzgado ahora mismo bolsonaro dijo que
Estados Unidos podría estar de todo esto
de esa manipulación electoral por parte
de Estados Unidos y que ha dicho que iba
a mandar a un amigo a revisar todas
estas informaciones Por otra parte hemos
destacado un artículo de o globo que
dice que la técnica del presidente del
tribunal supremo di morais para evitar
un poco cualquier tipo de
que se impida cualquier tipo de
celebración de este juicio en las
últimas semanas especuló concretamente
concretamente con que dos jueces podrían
pedir una revisión de este proceso
judicial y demoráis habría pedido a
estos dos magistrados que se
comprometieran con que el proceso iba a
seguir adelante porque podría ser
negativo para el país que este juicio no
avanzara un acuerdo que se habría
mantenido totalmente en secreto para
evitar la ira y la presión por parte del
bolsonarismo Bueno pero bolsonaro no se
quedó solo en estas críticas porque hoy
el medio francés Liberación publicó una
portada y un reportaje demoledor por no
decir menos contra el actual presidente
brasileño y demoledor porque la portada
de liberación es así Lula La decepción
además emplea ese titular en portugués
por tanto tiene mucho más
énfasis este medio francés contra el
actual mandatario brasileño dice que
Lula tiene problemas tanto internos como
en la escena internacional con polémicas
por sus posiciones también anti
atlantistas en el interior de este
reportaje pues extenso también en sus
críticas contra Lula dice titula el
reportaje Lula el Falso Amigo de los
occidentales su regreso a la escena
internacional ha decepcionado eso dice
Liberación composiciones alejadas de sus
socios tanto europeos como
estadounidenses además en el interno del
país dice está maniatado por la mayoría
bolsonarista en el congreso Marta vamos
a terminar con noticias más amables
sobre todo para Los Amantes del
reggaetón porque hoy la revista Rolling
Stone nos trae la entrevista más
personal de bad Bunny Así es Valentina
el Rolling Stone titula Bad Bunny
presenta el futuro de la música y vemos
a Bad Bunny a este cantante
puertorriqueño encadenado con esa
estética particular de este célebre
cantante probablemente la entrevista más
personal de esta mega estrella que los
últimos años se ha convertido Quizá en
el cantante más famoso de la escena
internacional Bad Bunny habla de cómo ha
sido esa transición en este último
lustro de hasta convertirse Pues en una
estrella Mundial de la música dice que a
veces odia la vida y odia a todo el
mundo pero que forma parte de esta de
este de esta profesión y dice que no
sabe qué hará en el futuro habla de sus
polémicas de sus éxitos y dice que este
año se lo tomará con calma que si no
saca ninguna canción Todo está bien pero
animamos a la gente a que lean la
entrevista porque es bien extensa y nos
muestra el lado más personal del
cantante puertorriqueño Pues claro que
sí seguramente sus seguidores van a
estar ahí muy pendientes y tal vez
conquiste a otros con esta faceta más
personal Marta Muchas gracias por esta
ampliación Gracias va